con unos nuevos comicios norteamericanos
a la vista
en el conocido como chef de Putin y
creador de los paramilitares de Wagner
se muestra más desafiante que nunca
antes negaba haber sido el creador de
esos grupos paramilitares y ahora al
contrario presume de ello también ha
anunciado la creación de centros de
investigación y desarrollo en distintas
ciudades rusas pero lo último es que ha
confirmado una interferencia rusa en los
comicios norteamericanos ha dicho que
Rusia ha interferido interfiere y que
interferirá en los comicios
norteamericanos en también en los que se
van a producir ahora ha dicho que lo va
a hacer de manera quirúrgica con cuidado
a su manera y ha hecho un símil muy
elocuente piensan extraer el hígado y el
riñón se supone que de Estados Unidos
durante la misma operación la relevancia
de prigosin cada día está más clara
sobre todo después de que hubiese
modificaciones en en la militar rusa que
le conectan todavía mejor con la cadena
de Mando del ejército de Vladimir Putin